PAUL KINLAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm here with one of my
good friends Glenn.
GLENN JONES: Hi, everybody.
So excuse some of the angles
that we've got at the moment.
We've just opened a brand new
recording studio in London.
I believe you're actually our
first external guest.
GLENN JONES: That's nice.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's cool.
So today is Web Intents
Wednesday.
This is all fortnightly or
biweekly coverage of what's
happening in the world
of Web Intents.
So, yep, this is our first week
in our new office with an
external guest, which
is pretty cool.
Just a bit about me.
So I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
I work at Chrome.
And in particular, I work on a
project called Web Intents,
which is what we're going
to talk about today.
And our first talk that we had,
I think it was about four
weeks ago, I had to
go on holiday.
I shouldn't say I had
to go on holiday.
I wasn't forced to
go on holiday.
My first one of these we did
in a different room.
We had Alex Kormorske, and we
were talking generally about
the project.
And we didn't actually get to
tell you anything about--
well, we did get to tell you
about Web Intents, but we
didn't get to show you kind of
how Web Intents worked in real
life inside the browser.
I know it was because my
machine wasn't set up
properly, but today, I think
we're all set up.
We're good to go, and I'll
give you a little
demonstration about what
Web Intents are.
But before we do that, I'd just
like to ask Glenn to talk
about himself kind of what
you're working on, what you've
been working in the past,
and what you've
done with Web Intents.
GLENN JONES: So I'm an
independent developer.
I've had my company in the
past, and I've been doing
JavaScript for quite
a long time.
And I became interested in Web
Intents about well over a year
ago, actually, a place in
Portland, IndieWebCamp, where
there was a big discussion that
went on about Web Intents
and the possibility there.
Chris Messini actually brought
the subject up, and that's
really where my fascination
started with it.
Now, my background is really
design and user experience as
well as doing coding.
So in the beginning of this
year, I tried to bring
together a group of people in
Brighton the event called
Design Push where we looked at
some more UI elements of this.
And I mean UI not just in terms
of what goes on in the
browser, but how you create
buttons, and the verbs you'd
use, and the language you would
use around it as well.
So that's one element of it.
But I've also been doing quite
a lot of experimenting with
the code as it progressed as
it's gone along, because I'm
quite interested to start using
it as soon as possible.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I think it was full
frontal last year?
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
I think they talked
full frontal.
I did actually manage at the end
of the talk to do a little
demo with some contact stuff,
because I'm quite interested
in how to use contacts and
information you find business
people's information and you
want to exchange backwards and
forwards between applications.
So I did a little demo
there by contacts.
PAUL KINLAN: So just to put, I
think, in a wider picture as
well, you were using a couple
of different APIs
like drag and drop--
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And then hooking up
these applications together
with Web Intents and then did
you also use a protocol
handler or--
GLENN JONES: I have done some
work with the protocol
handlers around picking
up telephone numbers
and things like that.
It's also to bring that
information in.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So that's kind of interesting,
really.
So thanks for that.
Just before we dive into
everything, I'm going to try
and give you a really good
demo of kind of what Web
Intents are, how they work
inside Chrome, because Chrome
has got an implementation of the
kind of the experimental
implementation, at
least, of Web
Intents inside the browser.
So I'm just going to produce,
do all this magic production
and switch cameras.
Cool.
So you should be able to see my
screen in front of me now.
This is just a normal
application.
It's called Imagemator.
It's a very simple app.
It's changed quite a bit since
my very first version.
We got some other people in to
make it all look pretty,
because the version prior to
this was all programmer art.
Yeah, you could tell it was
programmer art and stuff.
So this is our application.
All it needs to do is be able
to bring images into this
application and then do some
magic with it once--
I'll just do some general
magic with it.
So let me just show you kind of
in action and then I kind
of want to briefly show
you some code.
It won't be much code because I
think that's the part about
Web Intents, which
is pretty cool.
You can get applications just
to talk to each other with
very little code involved.
So anyway, this is our app.
We're going to pick an image.
There we are.
Now, as you can see, we have
a picker in front of us.
It's a little kind of dialogue
inside Chrome, which, in
theory, can't be spoofed by
any kind of normal web
application.
So the thing that happens here,
is we got a list of
applications that we can use,
capture browser screen, pick
file from Cloud File Picker,
and whole load of other
applications.
These are applications that I've
installed in Chrome kind
of knows, supports the action
of picking images.
We also have some suggestions
in the bottom of the screen,
web page screenshot, and
image, and Haystack.
These aren't installed, but
all this information about
what applications can
do is stored in
the Chrome Web Store.
So we can query the Chrome Web
Store to get a list of
applications that might
be able to help us
fulfill this action.
So anyway, let's have a
look at a quick demo.
So pick from Cloud
File Picker.
Cloud File Picker is just
another application that we
built that integrates
with Google drive.
It's kind of pretty cool.
So it's the normal kind of
one-pick experience, the
single-picker experience.
Let's choose an image.
This is one that people seem
to like of me sometimes.
This is actually a bug.
It should take you back to your
original application.
But as you can see, once we've
switch back, you can see the
image has been brought
back into our app.
One thing, which is in our
application, we can actually
do a couple of things.
We can either save it to the
cloud somewhere, share it
somewhere else, or
we can edit it.
So the demo that we
try and like to
show is Edit in Action.
So this is basically ask the
browser for a list of
applications that can support
image editing.
Not word document editing, not
video editing, just the
ability to edit images.
So we're going to edit in
Mememator, which is another
application I built.
And again, it looks a lot nicer
than it did originally.
So hot.
That's how we go.
Sorry.
Hot.
As you can see, the
image is updated.
There it is.
And scroll down, press
Done Editing.
And what should happen here,
is of the data that's been
edited in one application, has
been brought back into this
application.
So the really cool thing about
this is, is that we've
integrated three or four
different apps, but actually
all we've done is we've asked
the browser for some
functionality.
We haven't actually
had to do deep
integrations with these APIs.
And I just want to show
you the code.
Hopefully, this will work if
I get this just right.
And I'll zoom in a bit
so we can see it.
This is the entirety
of the application.
It's about 40 lines of code.
And as you can see here,
we have got Save
button click Action.
And then once we click the Save,
we fire off an intent.
There's two lines of code to go
off and find applications
that you want to use for common
actions across the web
and to deliver data.
I think personally, it's pretty
powerful, and this is
exactly what we're working on.
These are the types of things
that we are working on inside
Web Intents.
So back to the mainstream.
That was my demo of
the application.
It's kind of interesting.
We've got the ability to hook up
applications, which, at the
moment, from the way that we've
developed apps in the
past, we've never been
able to easily do.
GLENN JONES: No.
I mean if you think about any
other way of doing this like
with Olav on the server, the
amount of code you would need
to actually wire two
applications together using
Olav is really considerable
compared to what
we just looked at.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Actually, we didn't even
touch on that.
So the thing that's happening
right here is, normally, when
you have two applications, they
talk to each other on the
web at the moment, you kind of
pass the data from your web
app kind of client side
to the server.
The server talks to another
server with all the
authentication stuff going on
in the middle and then goes
from that service application
maybe back in the client app
on the other side.
And at least what we've been
trying to do in Web Intents,
in our case, is let's say, well,
quite often you have the
data in one browser tab and you
want to transition it to
another application in
another browser tab.
Why can't you just deliver the
data kind of from your page to
the service page inside
the browser?
So that's is kind of a really
good point is we're not
basically saying that you are
going to deliver all data by a
kind of client-side only
channels, but like the option,
in theory, is that--
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
A lot more simple.
A lot easier to implement.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I have a script of things
that we are going to talk
about today, at least.
So just to kind of go over
some of the things that
happened in the last
two weeks.
We've seen a lot of reports
about RSS integration and Atom
integration inside Chrome.
Just to kind of give everyone
like an overview of what this
actually means and what's
happened is--
Recently, I think it was at the
start of this month about
three weeks ago, when the stable
channel updated, we had
some functionality inside
Chrome, which would basically
say, well, whenever a user
visits an RSS feed, whether
it's the BBC news--
And I'll tell you what.
I'll just actually show
this as a demo now.
So when the user visits say the
BBC, for instance, I had
no idea it was going to
appear on the screen.
It clicks on an RSS feed.
In the past, what's happened
is that in Chrome, in
particular, it's just dumped
to the XML to the screen,
which is a pretty bad experience
for users.
What we've got instead is the
application will fire this
thing called the View Intent.
Let's say that the application
Chrome
will fire a View Intent.
So any RSS feed that you view
and visit, it will pop up this
picker that we see
in front of us.
So in this case, I've got two
applications, one is called
Message Board, which is by
Julian Jenistow in France.
I believe he's in France anyway,
feed intent viewer.
And this is how we view the
Feed Intent viewer.
So we've taken the data from BBC
news feed and presented it
back to Chrome.
So right now, we don't have the
ability to view the source
that we used to have in
Chrome, which a lot of
developers have been
asking for.
The Feed Intent Viewer is
designed and it's made by
Mikhail [INAUDIBLE]
Epstein.
It's basically designed to let
you do what you did in Chrome
originally.
Now, our plan, and we're still
working on this, our rough
plan is to basically say, well,
we want you to at least
be able to use the default from
something that wasn't
from Chrome in the first place
but also still take advantage
of Web Intents via the
picker that we have.
Hey, there's my picture.
GLENN JONES: I mean that's
really interesting, because
the viewer was one of the sort
of things unlike Edit and
Share which, to me, was a little
bit unexplained to
start with.
And this is a really nice
example of how the viewer
actually works in terms of
lousy type of alternative
perspective on something.
And a different way of viewing
it, gives you the choice of
how to view something.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So just to kind of jump back,
there is actually a couple of
different intents.
So we've kind of come up on
webintents.org with a list of
a kind of common actions
that we think the user
does across the web.
They view things on the web,
which is the View Intent, they
edit data, they share links,
images, videos.
They share a lot of
things on the web.
They pick data in and they save
things back out to the
cloud whether it's Dropbox,
Box.net, or Google Drive.
And so we've got five or six
different types of intents
that cover those actions.
And if we jump back to the
application, you'll see that
this is just a View Intent.
So like you said, it's a
different perspective on the
data that was on behind
the URL at the time.
So we've got a couple of
different applications.
RSS feed readers are a really
nice Chrome extension.
I actually want to talk about
this one a little bit more,
because the guy, Eric, who built
this application, he was
basically one of the first
people to actually integrate
with the View Intent.
And once he had done that, he
landed in Chrome, which is
then available to every
single user of Chrome.
Once it's in stable, it's
available to every
single user of Chrome.
And because we can present the
list of applications that you
can use from the Chrome Web
Store, like the discovery
mechanisms from find and
installed apps when you
haven't got one installed
already.
He got a whole lot of installs,
I think, and he can
tell you himself properly, he
had about 60,000 installs in
the first five or six days.
And he's got, I did a check on
the Chrome Web Store today,
and he's got to 220,000 installs
for his Chrome
extensions of Views Intents.
The feed reader as well is
another popular one that
[? Meihi ?]
made.
You have about, I think,
14,000 after the
first week or two.
So the way I kind of look at, is
that the more that you can
integrate with Chrome, the more
opportunities third-party
developers have to integrate
with the functionality that
was never available
to them before.
So that's basically an overview
of what's kind of
happened with the View
Intent at least.
GLENN JONES: I've
got a question.
So if you were to ever say,
when you view an image
usually, if you just purely
view an image and it just
shows you an image in the corner
of the screen, usually
in there, if that was ever to
opened up in a similar way, we
could build something that maybe
did a nice sort of black
screen, centered it, and maybe
even read some of the metadata
like what camera was used to
take that photograph or
something like that.
And provide a different view
yet again on something that
was very similar in terms
of viewing things.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I think that's kind of
interesting once you can start
to think about opening up
different types of file
formats and things that people
would just, like you said,
they would just see the white
screen for the rest of the
image, and like the image would
be at the top left.
If you could provide say,
Photoshop.com, for instance,
or the different sites and apps
and services, the ability
to say you know what,
we're going to
handle this data type.
Then I think that's a
powerful kind of app
ecosystem along the way.
You integrate directly with
the functionality of the
browser just to let the user
use those actions.
GLENN JONES: And even something
as simple as an
image, which you think, well,
you just display it.
It has information built into
it like the camera,
where it was taken.
You can even have enough data
information you can put a map
next to it and say this
image was taken here.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I mean that's some
of the goal.
I think the fair thing to say
at the moment is we've just
started kind of conservatively,
just RSS feeds
and Atom feeds.
We're going to get a whole lot
of feedback because some of
the stuff that we found so far
with just integrating the
ability to view an RSS feed is
it's driven the changes that
we've made to some of the kind
of things that we've made in
the spec recently.
So I'm going to comment on this
as well in a minute and
kind of give you a summary of
what's happened over the W3C
and on the specs about
Web Intents at least.
GLENN JONES: But as soon as you
start doing things like
that, people like me start
thinking about how can we use
this, and what's next thing
that can be done.
Just like that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
This is a powerful thing.
It's like you can kind
of get these little
hooks into the browser.
I mean, I want like Web Intents
integrated everywhere
across all the browser.
I honestly don't think it's
going to be there just yet.
I mean, if I go my way I would
do it, but I think right now
it's RSS feeds, Atom feeds,
things that people--
We've always had a not great
experience inside Chrome, and
we want let users
use those apps.
So I think it's quite good.
GLENN JONES: And you can see how
developers would like to
see the raw code.
There may be different
ways of exploring it.
We might spin it out and
stuff like that.
But for other people, it might
just presented to be in nice
paragraphs like I would have
in a normal RSS reader.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So that's pretty cool.
I just want to jump on to some
of the questions of things
that have happened
over the week.
So what's going to happen now is
I mean if you want to come
up with any questions even
if they're really
hard questions, right?
Just ask f it.
I just want to briefly talk
about some of the changes that
have happened in the past week
to the specification.
So the thing that's happened in
the moment is that we don't
want Web Intents to
be Chrome only.
I mean all the code has been
committed to Chrome, and it's
a WebKit, which means that any
WebKit-based browser can take
advantage of Web Intents.
But that's not the great
story, right?
I mean you've got three
hundred million users.
Potentially, you could take
advantage of Chrome.
But the rest of the internet
out there, the billions of
users who use the internet
now should be able to use
applications that they
want to use.
So our goal at the moment
is to try and get this
standardized and integrated
into other browsers.
So what's happening is we have
a group, which is kind of
shared between DAP on the W3C
and the public web apps group.
And then there's also some stuff
going on at the WHATWG
at the same time where we're
basically talking about the
things that we need from an API
to make these applications
interconnected, make it easy
for developers to do.
So some of the things that have
happened recently, and
literally it's like in the past
week, that we've made,
some of these that we've
talked about at least.
I'll give you a little
bit of background.
It's probably best that I give
you some background.
So the code that we had in the
past for talking to an
application inside Web Intents
at least was, you would invoke
an intent, you make an intent
object, give it the action.
So I need to share this image.
Well, I need to share
this thing.
Give it a data type that
thing that you want to
share, so an image.
I need to share an image.
And then you would actually
give the intent object the
data that you wanted to share.
And the way that we thought
about it originally was
actually this data object should
just be the raw data,
should be a BLOB or linked to
the URL link to where I save
the images.
And a lot of the feedback that
we had quite early on at least
and recently, is that it's
not enough information.
If you've got an image, there
might be some imitating code
like meta information
encoded into image.
But the problem that we've
got is, well, the name.
Where's the file come from?
If you're only passing the raw
data, a BLOB, it has no
concept of a file name.
URL might have a file name,
but it might be like a
randomly-generated ID that some
social networking inside
generates for an image, not the
actual physical name of
the image itself.
So we took all this feedback,
you know, people wanted all of
this extra metadata in.
And originally, we did
this thing called
SetExtra and GetExtra.
So you're basically set a key
value per problematically just
by a one-method call, one method
is called to set and
one method is called
to read it.
And you spoke to developers.
They hated it straight
away, right?
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It was kind of
analogous to the way that
Android works in a way you set
up an extra data but, it
didn't seem webby and when we
were building an application,
it was like, well, I have to
make 10 calls to set up.
Why can't you patch
a dictionary in?
And then we're thinking, OK.
Well we've got a dictionary,
we could just say this
actually is the dictionary.
And one of the things that we do
at the moment and there's a
current like a thread
on the W3C public
intents list at the moment.
The thread at the moment is
saying, well, why do we need
two objects?
Why do we need the actual data
object and the payload and the
actual object.
Why can't we just have one
object with an extra set of
metadata and the physical
data itself.
So we're kind of talk
about it right now.
We don't necessarily need to
make changes inside Web
Intent's implementation inside
Chrome because the way it
works inside Chrome at least
is that it shares
a JavaScript object.
So any object that you have that
can be serialized by this
structured clone algorithm can
be passed between Windows,
essentially.
GLENN JONES: I mean what you're
talking about makes
complete sense to me, because
quite often when you're
dealing with APIs, you have the
concept of envelopes where
you have like the metadata and
then within that, you have the
object that's being passed.
Often with API, that might be
things like if it's a list of
things, how many items
are there and
how that was achieved.
And this always seems
to be some sort of
envelope that goes on.
It's very rare that just the
data itself is passed across.
So it makes a lot of sense to
me that you would envelope
this somehow.
And although a dictionary is
good, my personal view is
often I already have an object
which is a representation of
the data from wherever I've
collected it from.
So as long as that's
understandable and everybody's
agreed on that as a structure
pass that
backwards and forwards.
PAUL KINLAN: So when you were
passing microformat data--
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
So--
PAUL KINLAN: How
did that work?
GLENN JONES: So strangely,
microformat data, when
microformats was first skimmered
up, they never had a
concept of a JSON structure
for it, which is actually
being rectified when they came
around to look up the
microdata format.
But part of the microdata format
is actually a very
well-defined JSON structure for
everything that the parser
has to bring out.
So I'm thinking of a specific
way, and it's
actually part of the spec.
So for microformat community, I
and a couple of other people
actually wrote a spec for how
you describe parse microformat
in JSON, and it's called ufJSON
or something like that.
So what's actually being passed
in the application I
was using is a ufJSON object.
It itself has an envelope.
It has things like what parser
was that passed it, how long
it took to parse it, the
original URL, and any base
HREF as well.
Because it has to actually
sometimes do some sort of
changes from absolute URLs to
relative to absolute URLs.
So there is little bits of
small metadata there.
And I encapsulated it
in that format.
PAUL KINLAN: I should have spoke
to you a lot more about
this earlier on.
Yeah.
So I think that's the kind of
model that I started to move
to at least anyway where we need
to be a little bit more
prescriptive about the data
formats even though you might
say you're passing an image
/png, there are actually types
of metadata that we want to
pass that you would sit
alongside the actual
raw data itself.
I remember when we first talked
about Web Intents, like
activity streams as well.
They have verbs and objects, and
at the time, it was like
well, actually they're pretty
well-defined objects.
They were defined XML at that
time, because they were meant
to be integrated
in Atom feeds.
The question that came up was
well, can you do that in JSON
And I think they had a method
for representing those objects
in JSON as well.
GLENN JONES: They did.
Yeah.
They moved on moved
on to do that.
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So with microdata,
that's part of the
HTML5 spec?
GLENN JONES: I believe so.
Yes.
It was one of the learnings
that came out of the whole
sort of microformats thing that
if you're going to embed
the parsers into the browsers,
then you have a way of
representation.
PAUL KINLAN: Is that serialized
with a two JSON
method or is that--
GLENN JONES: Now, you're getting
beyond maybe what my
knowledge is.
I looked at that, and that's
something I want to look at
actually next time.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Because that would be
kind of cool, right?
Because if you could just
literally pass a down element
as your data, understand that
actually well, you can't pass
down elements across but if we
could say is part of the
structure called the algorithm
or the algorithm that takes
data from like client to service
that he will call a
two-JSON method or something
on an object.
And if the HTML element
supported it and then went
through the rules for parsing
that into microdata and just
return the JSON,
that would be--
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
I mean it has to be for pulling
this information out
and it's a JavaScript type
that is built into the
browser, so it has to be JSON,
basically until it comes out.
PAUL KINLAN: That's really kind
of interesting, though
because I can see how--
GLENN JONES: Well, an
object literally.
We don't say JSON.
It's an object literally.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
An object in a way but that's
actually really interesting.
Because one of the things that
I was thinking about was you
could either write a Chrome
extension, for instance or
have it built into the browser
where if you detected these
objects like living inside the
page, is that you could
provide contextually-aware
actions off those objects.
So if you found like a
person it just looked
like a person's address.
GLENN JONES: So I mean the
technique you're talking about
is actually what I did.
Because I built a JavaScript
parser for microformats that
was built for people to
make extensions with.
And it was based off some
original work from
Mozilla ages ago.
But I took it and I stripped
it down, and it's called
microform app shift.
And it's actually the main
Chrome extension that displays
microformats uses this code.
And it does exactly what
you're talking about.
It's got method, which you pass
in the DOM element and it
passes back this ufJSON
structure for you.
PAUL KINLAN: And did you
manage that extension?
GLENN JONES: Someone else has
actually built the extension,
but I built the parse and I
built it in a way so that
people could build extensions
with it.
It's basically a library that I
built for people to put in.
PAUL KINLAN: So does it detect
it in the page or detect it
like in a little tab like a
little button across the top?
GLENN JONES: The library itself,
you basically have to
say give it a DOM element,
and it will
tell you whether this--
It will actually give
you a count as well.
So if you just want to see if
there's something in there.
So most of the extensions are
passing information first look
just for the trigger.
So they'll say, OK.
Has this got one of the classes
that would be a
top-level class.
In which case, now let's parse
a whole document and finds
it's structure.
And that's how most of the
microformats passing
extensions work.
PAUL KINLAN: I've got little
things get in my head.
I kind of got some ideas.
Yeah, I actually wouldn't mind
trying to do something like--
GLENN JONES: And one of the
things I wanted to do as well
as, obviously, the microdata
thing, I think, is not
something that I built a parser
for, because I know the
browser manufacturers and
vendors are going to build
them because it's part
of the HTML5 spec.
At some point, that
will come forward.
But I'd like to also do some
of this stuff for maybe the
Facebook Open Graph data and
newly the Twitter card systems
where, which are both two
different types of metadata
that are now being put into
websites on large scales
because of the SEO benefit and
the ability to get your
content shared into
social systems.
Of course, obviously, with
MicroTech we've also got our
sharing it to Google+.
But some parsers that do similar
things pull up data as
well and make that available.
PAUL KINLAN: I would actually
like to be able to just to
deliver objects that we find
on a web page to any
application that says
it can support it.
Wow.
OK.
Cool.
So jumping back to the subject,
we are getting rid of
the extras, GetExtra,
is extra.
So we getting ride of it.
It's part of kind of
a specification
that's done this process.
So obviously, we need to get
commitment from kind of all
participants in the group.
I think it looks pretty
positive.
Yeah.
So as extras, I was going to
say that the data you pass
along should have all this
extra information in it.
From a documentation point of
view, we need to be really
smart about how we document
the data that should be
embedded like in these data
types that gets passed,
because I get experience on
other systems where one might
expect a title and if a service
doesn't send a title,
then what happens, the client
application and all
that type of stuff.
So I think we can set some
really best practices in
documentation for how this
is going to work.
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
I mean my only point there
would be to, you reuse,
obviously, as much as
possibly out there.
Yeah, and that interestingly
these contacts, you've got
this beautiful thing the vCard
which is then being reused by
Microforms it's hCard.
It's nearly a one-to-one
match across.
So it's always about paving
those cow paths and reusing as
much as you possibly can.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So this is actually an
interesting point.
But I think the DAP
we're talking
about delivering contacts.
And I think we were talking
about the good and new contact
API but using intents but then
we'd have to describe the
delivery mechanism.
So it's kind of interesting
that we should--
GLENN JONES: So I saw some of
the original discussion on the
mailing list about this.
And it looks like some of the
mechanisms that they are using
are very similar to the popular
contacts work that was
done, which again, was actually
based on some of the
original hCard, vCard work.
So yours get some sort of
layering that's going on.
I think the interesting thing
is to make sure that you as
much as possible base things
on the earliest standard so
you don't have to translate so
much material from one thing
to another.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So Actually, I need to go back
to activity streams as well,
because they had a whole lot of
data formats that they were
automatically well-specified
out like especially
for images as well.
So recent changes to the API.
This hasn't happened yet,
but on the list,
this talk about Origin.
And what they're trying
to say is that--
So Origin is kind of
interesting HTTPS.
You obviously refer and
everything goes through.
When you do an HTTPS like an
HTTPS to HTTPS call at least,
just like a normal web request,
so the referrers was
always lost.
So they start to introduce
this idea of HTTP origin
header so that you could at
least understand the domain
that certain things came from.
And the request that's happened
recently on the Web
Intents mailing list on the W3C
is that can we include the
Origin information in the
payload for the data that's
being transferred between
Web Intents.
GLENN JONES: So I think there is
a really interesting point
there that I don't think
anybody's brought up yet,
which is if you include the
origin, so where the materials
come from, the receiving site
then can do some interesting
things with authentication,
which I think is the main
reason that people are
interested in this.
But it also has a slight darker
mechanism that could
kick in which would be that the
receiving site could say,
actually, I'm only going
to accept data from
certain other sites.
And actually be a blocking
mechanism, which is what we
found with OAuth because
originally there were two ways
of doing it, one which would
have been completely open, and
one OAuth site would have dealt
with another one and
stuff like that.
But it actually ended up with
people running white and black
lists for--
OK, We're going to open up,
and we're going to allow
people to OAuth between our
site maybe contacts or
something like that from
one site to another.
But we're only going to allow
authorized sites.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I mean that was actually some of
the thing that people were
asking for insight as
part of the spec.
GLENN JONES: And Origins
could give them that.
Because if--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I generally understood when we
were bursting with the API.
I didn't want client
applications to know about
service applications and service
applications to know
about client application.
At some point, they might be
able to discern information.
So if you passed an image that
was just the URL, and you have
like I don't know, like
image.twitter.com, whatever it
is, there's a good chance that
the image was shared from
Twitter or somewhere else,
but you're never
actually quite too sure.
It's one of those things that
this is the whole point about
specification that's done with
these processes is that we
talk these things out.
I don't know what
the answer is.
I don't think anyone knows.
It was only brought on the
list like two days ago.
GLENN JONES: I think it's a very
prickly subject, because
I can definitely see the
benefits for widening some of
these cases and stuff.
But it might be a reasonably
serious or downside to this,
which takes away some of the
ability of the browser to be
this completely transparent
mediator that sits in the
middle, and isn't sort of a--
You don't have to sort of
commercial linkages that you
get with the AuthAssist.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I don't quite notice yet.
I mean if Origin was going to be
a factor because you didn't
want to see data from certain
services, I'd rather that was
part of your declaration of what
you could say, you could
handle, so that the browser
could just not show your
application on the list.
Because I just think if you
deliver data to some
application, which is then going
to reject you, it's a
bad user experience, right?
GLENN JONES: Oh, definitely.
PAUL KINLAN: So I think the
answer is we don't quite
notice yet.
We're going to talk it out
and see what happens.
But as always, if you have any
feedback and you have any
particularly strong opinions
about kind of whether, for
instance, Origin should happen
or whether the way we're going
to deal with extra metadata,
please just get in the public
Web Intents list on the W3C.
Or if you're trying to work out
how to implement various
parts of the API, we've
also got Google
groups, discussion groups.
I encourage you to,
I think it's
called Web Intents Discuss.
I encourage everyone to go and
view those pages at least
anyway fire us some emails,
email me PaulKinlan.google.com
if you have any questions that
you want to get answers to
that you don't want to
put on your list.
We try and get everything in the
open, but if you want to
talk to me, that's
fine as well.
That's cool.
So let me jump back.
I think we actually covered
quite a lot of ground.
I've actually run out of the
things I was supposed to go
over at some point.
Yeah.
I mean the interesting thing I
find about Web Intents is that
for me, at least, I've learned
a lot about the specification
and standardization process.
It's been pretty good.
Other than that, everyone has
been kind of open in talking
about the things
that they want.
We have on the device group at
least, people wanting to
integrate with devices outside
of your machine.
I did a podcast for SitePoint
last week, and they basically
said, what's the most
exciting thing.
I've learned so much.
We can integrate devices outside
of your machine.
So the idea is like Web Intents,
the scope is very
much firmly in connecting web
applications to other web
applications.
GLENN JONES: Yeah.
We saw how distant the design
push when we were talking
about the different use cases.
And it sort of stymied off at
the beginning of the day when
we were trying to explain to
a lot the UX designers who
turned up to the event all the
different possible ways it
could be used.
That they focused initially on
the whole share bit and the
share buttons, because that's
a really common use case.
But as the day went on, people
became more and more
interested in the idea of
sharing more complex data
between applications and less
interested in the more obvious
sort of sharing in the Intents
in the beginning, which I
found really interesting that
sort of shift as people start
to see the broader picture.
PAUL KINLAN: I always think
the other intents are more
interesting than share.
I mean share is the one that
everyone just says we just
need to sort some way of getting
rid of all of these
buttons, all of these different
options inside
pages, and is Web Intents
going to do that.
I think yes, you can.
I think there's a whole lot of
stuff that has to be solved
around branding, which we talked
about this design push
around branding and kind of let
users understand that the
button that they're going to
click on is going to let them
share to their preferred
network.
Social reinforcement, that was
actually one of the areas that
you talked about quite a lot
was social reinforcement.
The fact that you see that your
friends have done certain
actions on the page is actually
quite influential.
And Web Intents doesn't solve
that, it doesn't say that
well, you'd rather click
on this type of thing.
GLENN JONES: I think if you
look at the share and what
you're going through some of the
plus and minus points of
in terms of moving over to Web
Intents there is a definite
case for doing it, but the
difference between the benefit
you get from a share, I think,
from looking at the benefit
you'll get from some of these
edit-type functionality.
You were just sharing about
moving data from one
application to the editor and
bringing it back again.
Then the benefit is
really massive.
It's quite hard to achieve
it any other way.
Whereas, at the moment, we have
something that sort of
works with the shares of
everybody doesn't like it.
It's not quite what we want and
stuff, but it's sort of
billions of interactions every
year using those bonds.
But with the edit,
that's actually a
completely new game.
And I think, so that's
where it is.
I think there is a difference
between
your perceived benefit.
You can actually see the benefit
we implemented than
the more edit ones.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I've been honestly surprised
about the uptake of the shared
view and RSS feeds.
I think that's got a
lot of potential.
I'm always talking to people,
and say, what is the most
popular or the best intent.
It's like naming one of
you're kinds, right?
It's like you're my
favorite son.
But it's like the idea behind
it was like well, actually I
think share is the one that
everyone is going to see to
think about.
Actually, things like
edit, pick and save.
The cycle of taking data from
one app, manipulating it, then
sending it back to like Dropbox
or these types of
services is actually
really powerful.
And that's the one that
will be kind of--
Those three will be the ones
that will really be take off.
Obviously, we have to do a
whole lot of work to get
partners, and services,
and everything to
integrate into that.
But when you look at the client,
the browser as the
client, then you only
need services to
fulfill one side of it.
And I think that's where the
view, especially view in RSS
and view in Atom feeds they've
been really popular so far is
that actually you only have to
tell the server like it's
doing great with the browser
rather than integrate with
other applications.
At some point in the future,
people will start to say,
well, we're going to fire a view
feed intent ourselves a
lot rather than have the browser
do it automatically
and all those type of things.
And then those apps will
start to build up.
So you will get more clients
and services, and client
services in clients and
it will grow out.
I think it will be
kind of cool.
Yeah.
I've been kind of just going
on all over the place.
I actually want to
show one thing.
Let me just flip back
to the screen share.
One other piece of information
before we get into questions.
We've got seven questions
to go through.
One of them was a
little bit spam.
Someone tried to in-script
inject on the page.
There it is.
He's deleted.
I hope it didn't work.
I'm pretty sure it
didn't work.
But the thing that happened
recently is Greg Billock one
of our engineers over in Los
Angeles, fixed a bug that I've
had with Web Intents for a long
time, which is that you
can never invoke Web Intent
from a browser action.
And for those who don't know
about Chrome, at least, a
browser action is this
little thing here.
It's at the top right of the
screen, content for the aware
action, essentially.
So I've got a couple.
I made a few.
It's now RSS Feed One, which
is the RSS feed reader, an
extension that Eric wrote.
This is share, right?
This is like a share button,
just an extension.
It's not integrated, right?
It's just an extension
I built with Chrome.
But as you can see, we can fire
the intent, so we could
say, I'll have to check with
Google+ because it's not a
public account.
It's my Web Intents account
which no one ever uses.
So no one will ever
see the demo.
Well, there we go pass the
moderator link and the page we
just shared.
Questions, please from Web
Intents live on air.
So if you see this now, it's
history being made.
We just shared up that part from
the browser, but that's
because Greg implemented this
fix, which allows you to do
these types of things.
GLENN JONES: Is it the same sort
of stuff where it's just
the context menu as well.
You can use--
PAUL KINLAN: So actually this
is an extension I wrote.
This is like the image you can
share like link to images not
actually sharing the raw history
sharing the link to
the image data.
GLENN JONES: Which
is really nice.
Because you could imagine things
like video as well and
all sorts of different
types of media that
could be on the page.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So it can do videos, audio
files, share links, when it
knows it's sharing a
link, not an image.
Oh, there's another
one as well.
Share a link to an image
and link share link.
So I think it's pretty cool.
It opens up quite
a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
It can do videos, RSS
feed, context menu.
Obviously, it can do RSS feeds
because it's a link.
GLENN JONES: It gets to this
point where you can actually
start to share elements of the
page, not just the whole page
itself with context menu.
PAUL KINLAN: And it doesn't have
to actually be built into
the browser it can have an
extension, which so clearly.
GLENN JONES: I could imagine
if you can swipe something
like a piece of text, it doesn't
mean you can have an
equivalent like a share
to a quoting type.
PAUL KINLAN: I mean,
exactly right.
You shared a tumbler as a quote
rather than as a link.
Those t of things would
be pretty cool.
So actually, that's why I wanted
to speak with the guys
who did the microform extension,
because what I was
thinking of is if you could
detect things on the page
where there's a person, you
could do a right click context
to ware menu and then
say, share this to
your address book.
Or share this to-- there's
different types of actions.
That would be really cool.
OK.
I'll get in contact.
So if you're watching this,
I'll go after you.
So anyway, we've got five
minutes left and we're only
supposed to be here
for 45 minutes.
Questions.
He asked if I know it.
It seems like a lot of stuff
from anon somewhere.
seems like a lot of stuff that
pretty much deals on Web
Intents, first becoming
a standard.
Could you outline the rough
process of what needs to
happen before it's accepted,
what state once Web Intents is
up, and any contribution
feedback we can help to
accelerate it's approval.
Wow.
I So yeah, the process is
pretty interesting.
We are part of the W3C
process right now.
We're first public working
draft, which is different when
editors draft.
An editor's draft is pretty
much, I think any member can
make an editor's draft.
Then it needs to get accepted,
I believe, at least by one
group that goes to a first
public working draft.
You then work on it.
It's a specification.
It's not standard at that point,
but you're kind of
working towards that process.
So we're still at that first
public working draft.
I think we've got a couple
of months to iron
all the stuff out.
And then we have I believe a
corporate consensus later on
and then a whole lot
of other stuff.
Just to put it bluntly,
we're at the very
first, the second stage.
The very first stage is
just get on there.
The second stage is where
we are right now.
GLENN JONES: There's been
a lot of refinement.
Hasn't it?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
There's a lot of refinement.
So the general process is
feedback that either I capture
from the Web and kind of
a general sentiment.
I try and deliver it to the
public intents group, a public
Web Intents group at
least on the W3C.
Or we, and I encourage everyone
who kind of want to
see the API change for a
specific reason or even just
to say that we support this
kind of way of working all
those types of things, use
cases and a whole loat of
other stuff, is to go on the
public Web Intents list on the
W3C and then just give
us your feedback.
Because it's like if we
developed this API in complete
isolation, we might find it
doesn't serve a ninth of some
of the things that we want.
A ninth of the developers
don't use it.
And if they don't use it, we
don't get users, which means
we don't get any one
benefit from this.
GLENN JONES: The most useful
thing I've always found to
have input.
Because it's quite difficult to
get involved with the spec
element of it because of the
way it works is to actually
talk about use cases that you
have specific things.
And if you can't find out a way
of doing it using what's
already been said, to
ask the question.
I have this use case,
I want to do this.
How would I do it like this?
Because that actually provides
the developers with a really
interesting sort of hook
to think about things.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
That's what happens, right?
That's what's happening with the
Origin talk at the moment
is there a very specific use
case that someone wants to
solve, which honestly we can't
solve right now in Intents the
way the specification
is designed.
So it's like do we either accept
it, reject it, or some
kind of where in between.
And that's the whole process
is right now.
It's like we're at this
stage where we're just
talking about it.
The idea of Web Intents being it
needs to be a standard for
people to implement it, I think
it depends on usage
inside the browser, different
usage of services.
Because services kind of adopt
it once it's in one browser.
But we don't want it to
be a one browser.
We want it to be across multiple
browsers and that's a
whole heap of extra work
that needs to go on in
conversations that happened with
all the browser vendors.
The thing I would say is that it
is going into WebKit, which
means that if you're a browser
vendor who implants WebKit or
imports a WebKit, as long as
you can take this ports
across, you could, in the
theory, turn on Web Intents
whether you choose to or not.
You just have to implement
all the rest of the
logic behind it.
So yeah, that's kind of
roughly where we are.
Next question.
So Patrick Lord.
I know that name.
If Web Intents are meant to
replace shared buttons among
other things, would there be a
way to know if you've already
shared something?
For example, if I plus one
something, the plus one button
shows up red.
Are there plans in Web Intents
to support that?
So I kind of answered that
before where we didn't have--
Web Intents doesn't kind of do
that social proof and remind
and other things that
you've done.
It's not designed to actually
say well, you know what,
you've shared this
link before.
You might not want to share
it again and all
those types of things.
The thing I would say and your
opinion is completely valid
and appreciated, is that I think
there are the server,
services and add this on this
recently, where add this with
integrated with Web Intents
as well as the services.
But they still provide that
aggregation and social proof.
So it's still a widget that does
kind of all the work for
account on what's happening on
the social web, for instance.
But that's their service.
They provide a whole lot of
services outside of the just
share and people think they're
sharing services.
It's like they're not just that,
they're analytics, using
management metrics and all
those types of things.
I personally think that's
where that's going to
live and still is.
GLENN JONES: I think there is
an answer to this particular
question in that there's two
ways this could happen.
So when this [INAUDIBLE]
goes off, you're actually within
Web Intents [INAUDIBLE]
it's just not giving
the return.
There should be like a success
return back to the site.
And at that point, you as
the site can recall that
information that that's
being done.
And then mark that button,
because the button is actually
controlled by you.
So you kick it off, you design
it, it's got your images or
text in it, and hook in the
intents by using the
JavaScript onClick or whatever
you're going to use.
So you could do it that way or
a slightly worse way would be
you don't get the
success just to
actually recall from anywhere.
Just recall to click.
That doesn't say that it's
actually successfully been
done, but at least
you know that's
someone has clicked there.
So I think there is mechanisms
to do it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I think there is.
And I think there will
be services that
pop up that do it.
I think, at least, are good
example of their entering Web
Intents because it's like built
into the platform, but
at the same time sharing isn't
their main, but they'll tell
you what their main
business is.
But it's like it's the rest of
what they offer is the thing
that they do, analytics,
metrics, all of
those types of things.
Just the facility to share
is one very small aspect.
It's a kind of interest actually
this type of new +1
something, you've shared this,
I think that's very specific
just to the share intent.
I've never seen maybe there is,
maybe there isn't safe,
you've already saved this.
Great.
But You might want to save it
again to a different service
all that type of stuff.
So I can't imagine some other
intent using this type of--
GLENN JONES: No.
Because they don't use
the same sort.
When we talked earlier about
social proof, that's a bit
like the where you get the like
the little icons of the
people who have already
done this in
part in social network.
It's not basically an
encouragement or a number that
tells you x number of people
have done this.
It's a way of encouraging
you to do it.
And you're right.
At the moment, I've only ever
seen it used in the terms of
the share-type implementations
or the Likes and stuff like
that, which are a very
similar thing.
PAUL KINLAN: We're actually
really running out of time.
So I'm really sorry
about this.
So how will the UX work for
Chrome packaged apps?
Will this selected external app
open inside the app itself
or hand folks over to a separate
browser window, and
is app not as magical?
or will there be a way
to send that intent
on to packaged apps?
So yeah.
We got this thing called
Explicit Intents, b which
allow you to deliver data
to a known application.
I know you've got a whole load
of question about suggestions,
which I don't believe we've
implanted just yet.
GLENN JONES: We'll leave
that for the day.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
But explicit intent they tend
to deliver data from one app
to another directly if
you know about it.
The way it's going to work in
packaged apps, I mean, the way
it actually works in
Chrome now is it
always opens a new tab.
If it's a package app, the new
style packaged app is showed
up in a brand new instance of
the application, because you
won't have any browser Chrome.
So yes is the answer.
Is there a shim or a polyfill
for Web Intents?
I think the answer is no.
How could we collaborate
to make one?
There is one, webintents.org/w
ebintents.min.js.
It tries to emulate Web
Intents, the API.
It needs update.
It needs some local Firefox.
I had to turn on Security
Policy, which broke in
Firefox, but still worked
in Chrome and WebKit.
The interesting thing is the
Web Intents shim actually
worked on Android, iPhone,
Opera as well.
So there is a shim, Github
account, github.com/paulk
inlan/webintents.
I would love your support.
If you can offer any support
for building out the
shim, please do.
I'm really looking forward
to getting some.
And this is the last question
before I'll get kicked off.
Is most development around Web
Intents focused on the Chrome
extension or the cross browser
pure JS implementation?
Can I happily work and use Web
Intents from Firefox and with
Chrome browser at the moment?
It's both.
We can offer a good experience
inside Chrome right now and
kind of prototype and rapidly
develop things that aren't
purely available in
the open web.
We've landed the intent tag.
The intent tag actually exists
in the Web Intents source
space, it's just not enabled.
You can't run it inside there.
If we introduce these things,
and we get a hold of
developers building on the
public open web, then it's
harder to take back
those things.
You can still take back those
changes, but it's harder.
So inside, there's a relatively
closed ecosystem as
opposed inside the Chrome--
GLENN JONES: Can you switch on
the dev flag at the moment,
the intent tag?
PAUL KINLAN: Not the
intent tag, no.
It's a compile-type flag.
There's a whole lot of
things we have to
work out around that.
So that's not why it's
not available
just there, just yet.
To counteract that, for other
browsers, we do have the shim.
Like I said, we need as much
help as possible to kind of
keep that up to date.
So please forward to my
repository, follow me as well,
and we'll go from there.
So that's it.
I believe that is it.
I would like to thank you
very much for watching.
I'd like to thank Glenn
for participating.
I know this is very
last minute.
He came along for a chat and
said, you know what?
We're going to go on
air in a minute.
Do you want to join in.
GLENN JONES: That's fine.
We had our chat on air.
PAUL KINLAN: And so that's
pretty cool.
So yes.
Thank you very much.
I will be back again in two
weeks, but I'll be in America
next time rather than London.
So thank you and good bye.
GLENN JONES: Thank you.